coming together in times of war after
days of talks Israel's prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu and an opposition
leader have agreed to form a temporary
emergency Unity government that includes
leader of the opposition National Unity
party [__] Benny Gant had conditions and
he got what he wanted a five member
so-called War management cabinet with a
wealth of military experience it
includes himself the Prime Minister
defense and strategic Affairs ministers
and former Army Chief Gaddy Eisen Cott a
decision likely to appease the public
after Israel's major failure to stop
Saturday's Hamas attack that led to the
war on
Gaza I want this to be good for everyone
we need calm and unity they needed to
stop with all this political
mess this is important to reassure the
nation and all the parents that lost
their loved ones and white people with a
sense of security there should be Unity
amongst us here we've reached a
catastrophic
level as the death toll continues to
rise on both sides Israel faces a war on
several fronts despite the biggest
military mobilization in Israel's 75e
history it's still not been able to
secure the region near the border with
Gaza several days after it was attacked
by Hamas Fighters Israel's response has
been a ferocious one air strikes on
gaza's civilian population continues
indiscriminately but Hamas Rockets keep
being fired from Gaza while the majority
have been intercepted by Israel's
anti-missile system some are getting
through and on Wednesday a medical
center in the southern city of ashalon
was hit for a second time tensions on
the border with Lebanon have also been
high the arrival of US military
equipment on Israeli soil and a plan
visit by US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin on Thursday is a welcome sign
for Israelis that with the help of its
biggest allive us it is not alone in
this war we have the back of the Israeli
people we have their back today we'll
have it tomorrow we will have it every
day and as foreign Nationals continue to
be evacuated Palestinians in Gaza fear
the worst is yet to come s AL jaaz West
Jerusalem well Al jazer is senior
political analyst maram bishara says
Netanyahu has a Personal
Agenda he would like the war to be
prolonged as much as possible because
sooner or later he's going to be held
accountable for both corruption where he
was indicted on four charges as well as
for having this major Fiasco under his
watch so he has a Personal Agenda they
have a different kind of agenda these
are two serious professional military
men Extreme as they are and they would
want to run the war War according to the
parameters of the military establishment
having said all of that this is still
all theoretical and as you said
political I think the big issue is how
will they conduct this war because now
they've been bombing and they probably
bomb what now almost 2,000 targets
within within Gaza Hamas is still
shooting Rockets still holding hostages
people are dying right left and Center
my estimate is probably we're still
we're already talking about 2,000
although the numbers counted are less
than that and now Gant in a video
talking to Israeli soldiers he said we
are only the offensive we are confident
and next will be the ground Invasion
really so they are actually preparing
and they have already deployed 100,000
Israeli soldiers to the southern borders
around Gaza they've already as we
reported uh called up 360,000
uh reservists from the military and
hence they are in fact with the
artillery with the tanks and everything
isse preparing for ground
invasion